i will introduce you our next speaker is
jared mclean from google
and he will tell us about what the
foundations of quantum computer science
can teach us about chemistry
yeah great thanks a lot for the
invitation to to talk about this work
so i i feel like i need to start a
little bit by giving some context for
the actual
uh perspective that i'm going to talk
about so when i got
an invitation sometime last week to talk
about this paper in particular
uh to this crowd i was a little bit
surprised because i think it's a bit
different
uh if you look into it than
some of the other work that's been
talked about at this conference which
involves you know many sophisticated
proofs and great results
uh whereas this paper this paper is more
of a perspective more of a high level
kind of musing on ideas and to be honest
its origin was sort of that
i was invited to by a chemistry journal
uh to write a perspective about the
future of quantum computing
and chemistry and i'd seen probably
enough and maybe written my fair share
of these papers where we talk about
putting a molecule
into a quantum computer we do it much
faster
do everything we'd like to do and you
know three or four months later we're
all in a
solar punk utopia that's not to say i
don't believe in the power
of quantum computing for chemistry but i
wanted to use this opportunity to kind
of share
a recent perspective that i'd gained
which was something about the power of
data and how that affects
what we think about physical simulation
so if you look at this author list
you'll notice that it's a
pretty strong collection of chemists
with one bold
computer scientist at the end who is
willing to to sign on with our uh
insanity and basically what we do is try
to offer
some of this perspective kind of push in
different directions in chemistry
and hopefully inspire chemists to look
more at
quantum computer science and maybe
inspire quantum computer scientists to
look a little bit
in the other direction as well so like i
said
we don't prove anything new in this
paper i'll reference some results in the
middle of this
talk um that are from a different paper
that have some proofs associated
with them but i think it'll be a bit
different i hope that it's
fun it will probably be contentious
and upset some people that are watching
it but if it inspires one new
interesting thought
uh through that window of blind rage
then i'm happy
so with that i wanted to kind of say
start off by talking a little bit about
what
simulating chemistry can mean um and so
traditionally we talk about
uh taking some structure or some set of
reagents and actually i'm going to talk
about many different parts of chemistry
today not just
a electronic structure or dynamics or
things like that
and from that i hope to gain some amount
of understanding
about that molecule so say how it
absorbs light
how it complexes with other species
maybe i'd like to know how to reach that
molecule from some set of reagents
uh and if i can understand aspects of it
then i get some element of control
if i know why molecules absorb light
then i can start to design
better photovoltaics if i know why they
complex with other species
maybe i can understand chemical
reactions a bit better or i can
start to inhibit reactions that i don't
want and guide evolutions
or i can get platinum out of my
catalytic converters finally
and try to move towards less expensive
metals
and so when we simulate chemistry what
do we typically do
versus what we we could have done so
let's take a scenario for example where
i'm going to simulate chemistry
without reference to the history of
chemical simulation so imagine that i'm
basically in a scenario
where i've have some concept of atoms
and molecules
and now i've just received my first
computer
and someone told me that there are for
example these
uh things that i'd like to do i'd like
to answer about these
molecules and so what are those
questions often
so i end up with some amount of products
afterwards and i start to ask myself
questions perhaps these are my target
for what i get out
like how long does this reaction
typically take or
does this ever actually happen in a
realistic uh
scenario or does this product simply
never appear
and so i'm going to take my computer
with out my knowledge of chemistry and
i'm going to basically say well someone
told me
that there's at least these laws of
motion either newton's dynamics for
moving around some classical nuclei at
an approximate potential
or this full schrodinger dynamics where
i have seemingly exact hamiltonian
and sometimes i can just afford to
simulate one copy
so what can i do i can simulate it i can
let these things bounce around
i can wait for a really long time i can
wait for more time
have i waited for enough time i'm not
sure
and i asked does this product come out
and can i really answer this question
and so i spent a lot of time um and you
kind of start to say well
maybe this is not the most effective
simulation strategy
but we have quantum computers these days
and so surely this will
will help me out and so what's one thing
that we can say
from what we've learned about the study
of quantum computers even before we've
had them
available to us is kind of the limits of
what this type
of simulation can do so if i close my
eyes i've learned nothing from nature
i plow forward with dynamics and i hope
for the best what can i learn
and so basically the setup here is that
i have some initial state that i'm
interested in
i have a hamiltonian it's guided by
say the schrodinger equation and now i
have my quantum computer i can do these
great
exact quantum dynamics and there's been
wonderful developments in this area it's
kind of a rapidly developing field where
you can get
nearly numerically exact evolutions um
in a time that's sort of sublinear in
the number of basis functions so
quantum computers are really good at
quantum dynamics
uh and exact classical competition seems
to hit an exponential wall in this area
because while ground states were quite
good
at kind of arbitrary dynamics seem to
not have as much structure as we'd
appreciate
uh the entanglement truncation is really
hard things don't go as well as we'd
like
and so you can start to look at this and
if you're saying not steeped in quantum
computing people in chemistry start to
believe well
perhaps this can do almost arbitrary
computations if i speed things up fast
enough
then maybe i can actually do what i just
said but faster than nature can do it
and i can still reach
interesting answers and sort of what
basically intuition and i'm going to
abuse a result a little bit here
and talk about that tells us is that
even a quantum computer has limits
basically we expect the simulation time
of a physical system
to be at least some multiple greater
than the physical time the intuitive
reason without any theorems
is just to say that if a system could
simulate itself
faster than it ran then it could sort of
recursively do that and do any
computation instantly and i'm leaning a
little bit
on the no fast forwarding theorem here
which of course is a query complexity
result so it's not
directly applicable you have to add a
bunch of caveats to this
to what you want to say but essentially
you want to say that
the field of quantum computer science is
already studied to some extent
the limits of what such a perfect device
can do and now if i come in and tell you
that some chemical reactions
with 10 to the 23 molecules before we
start to see
appreciable reaction rates can take
hours what chance does a single
realization of this have with any kind
of multiplier where c
is greater than one and so you're
looking at this and you say oh
that's not so good um but why are you
even talking about dynamics like um
for these types of things doesn't
everyone just
go to their favorite tried and true
electronic structure
calculation and of course you we've seen
this slide appear
or rather this quote appear many times
that basically the underlying physical
laws for chemistry
are just waiting for us to grab as we
solve this sort of time
independent schrodinger equation and so
how did we actually
reach this why is this a useful
perspective because if
you kind of recall back to your early
quantum mechanics courses
uh the dynamics and the stationary
estate kind of perspective
contain more or less the same
information as input in both cases
you're given a hamiltonian
in one you're given an initial state but
essentially
it's usually a hop skip and a jump to go
from the dynamics picture to stationary
states and it's just asserted to you
that these will be the important states
for for reasons you'll understand at
some point
um and why is this a useful perspective
and
i'm going to claim that it's because we
have additional information that we sort
of got from
the outside world one piece of
information
is for example that this is limited to
physical time scales
while on the other hand the world is not
actively exploding though it's funny as
i was making this slide a wildfire broke
out
across the river from me and i debated
maybe i should take the burning globe
off
the slide but we persist nonetheless and
so
thermodynamics is often predictive of
long-time behavior
because things tend to have enough time
to settle into states where
t going to infinity so this
thermodynamic limit
is predictive of a long time scale
that i actually care about so of course
there are limits to this for example no
living things are at thermodynamic
equilibrium the folksman's dog is a
great example of this but often these
stationary states also have the
additional structure
that they're well approximated more so
than the dynamics
and so by making an approximate answer
to the infinite time limit
i seem to be able to jump the line on
these physical time scale constraints
and so i make predictions on time scales
that are much beyond this fast
forwarding limit
and we know of course there are no free
lunches thermo can't be better for all
systems
our physical system special i think this
gets to some of the questions that brian
was asking
and in the worst cases you expect to
sort of have to enumerate all of your
states
or diagonalize but is this actually a
useful perspective and i'm going to
tease on that a little bit but before i
do i'm going to make the chemical
problems a little bit
start to make them a little bit harder
and so
we've talked a lot about of course about
thermodynamics in the sense that
these stationary states are predictive
because we look around in our world and
we notice that we're at some temperature
and for electronic temperature time
scales or for electronic
temperature scales this often means
we're very close to or entirely in the
ground state
so this means i can predict something
about my long time behavior
if i can wait long enough but in some
cases
so for example i'll go into a laboratory
i'll have some set of chemical reagents
each of these spheres you can just
uh believe is some chemical that i got
out of my
sigma aldridge catalog and i put them
into a vial
and i'd like to say which of these two
products do i get more of
um one in fact has much lower energy
than the other according to some very
accurate calculation i did
but you talked to your friend uh who
actually went and did the experiment and
they've never seen the top one in any
experiment they've ever done
and that's because if you just talk
about sort of these ground states on
their own
they aren't really predictive of the
rates at which things happen
um and so we try to shoehorn some of
this back into chemistry
um by instead of just doing the
thermodynamics of stable nuclear
configurations trying to identify
paths and do the thermodynamics of these
paths
but we often have already injected some
amount of classical
observational information which is going
to be a kind of recurring theme
throughout this talk that allows this to
be kind of a good analysis
why should it take one dominant path why
is this a good approximation
should it take all of them if i were to
include the nuclei for example into my
quantum calculation
so all of my nuclei here of course
classical
under this born oppenheimer
approximation um
if i made them quantum how would i
actually start to to do this calculation
um in fact this pre-information of
keeping things in a nuclei classical
has more value than perhaps you might
imagine as an approximation
so if you actually try to go make all of
your nuclei quantum
you've in principle made everything more
accurate so you should be happy
but what you might be left with is a bit
of a nuclear electron soup
so things that are sort of degenerate
for other reasons you might get
superpositions of them it can be
hard actually to go back and find
molecules after you've lost them
in the soup you have other problems like
center of mass translation modes are now
good eigenstates
or near-good eigenstates so this can
become problematic as well
and in fact keeping it real can go quite
wrong
for examples that are incredibly simple
so
take for example a hydrogen chloride
just an hcl
strong acid that you might use in many
different experiments
and if i make everything quantum no
one's ever shown me the outside world i
just take my
quantum soup out of it and start doing
my calculation
i have the schrodinger equation
everything's perfectly exact
and i realize uh and my solutions also
realize
that because this diatomic molecule so
has this rotational symmetry my solution
should uh respect that symmetry also
so i do this calculation and what i find
depicted by one sphere is sort of a
chlorine atom
enveloped by a sphere of hydrogen and
now i do my dipole moment calculation
and i find that it's zero
great i've learned wonderful physics but
then someone comes along
and tells me that they've pinned the
classical nuclei
uh which is of course as we've talked
about now wrong because it doesn't have
the right symmetry
i do a calculation and get one dubai
which is some unit of dipole moment that
can dislike to use
and then someone does an experiment and
it matches this wrong model perfectly
so of course this is an example of
spontaneous symmetry breaking but how
would i have known this without some
sort of data from the outside world
to help me out with this calculation so
in this case the more correct quantum
answer was not
actually what i was looking for i was
looking for the additional knowledge
that in fact
every realization of this molecule that
we've seen in a lab
is symmetry broken by some external
environment
so what can we say about the predictive
power of free energies and this sort is
a preamble
to the next part so for example what
have we learned recently
about certain parts of models and
physics
related to computational hardness so
we've seen for example that we can't
fast forward things very far
we've seen that perhaps you can
enumerate all these states though
and then take some reduced number like a
thermodynamic free energy and try to use
that predictively
and i think interestingly a thing that
we can contribute or rather computer
scientists who have proven these things
can contribute
is that some questions which seem very
reasonable and actually i think are
quite applicable like does a system ever
thermalize
does a system have an electronic gap
some large limit
will molecule x ever form from
constituents y
are in fact undecidable and so as a mere
mortal chemist i spent a long time
trying to wrap my head around this
like what this could possibly mean and
then i found this nice paper by chris
moore where he tried to put
undecidability into a physical context
and this is kind of the definition that
i lean on to make some of these
analogies
even though you might find it a little
bit uh grating if you try to go to a
formal extent and what that says is that
physical
undecidability and i'm paraphrasing a
bit as a system evolves forward in time
there are sudden qualitative changes
that cannot be predicted in any way
except evolving it forward in time and
seeing if it happens
and no answer in finite time can
indicate that it will never happen so
something happening here would be like
the halting of a halting problem and so
you can say
okay well we already have hard enough
time relating
you know finite complexity theory
results why are we going to to bring in
this kind of undecidability questions
and i'm going to lean on this kind of
old but useful quote
all models are wrong but some are useful
and so if we consider
these physical systems that for example
i'm going to look at the problem of
chemical synthesis
so in this case i'm going to have some
box of reagents
and i can just keep adding more if i
need to add more
and i'm going to ask does this molecule
on the right ever come out
and we suspect that the universe is
finite so you're very tempted to then
say well at least formally
i can box up the entire universe and do
a set of discrete possibilities there'll
be some size at which
i don't need to add more reagents so i
just choose that size and i start doing
all these combinatorial calculations of
free energy
or some analog for it and say okay
now that i found this one has the lowest
free energy
i can say that it will eventually show
up
um and what i want to say is you can
take that perspective
you can enumerate and tell me about the
exponentially small probabilities
compare but it doesn't seem actually as
close of a match to what you would see
for example if you went into a lab or
really thought about the complexities of
emerging chemical systems basically real
systems can in fact continue to borrow
from the environment
sometimes they have these side reactions
which lock them in states that mean for
the foreseeable future not only will you
not
go back to thermodynamic equilibrium but
you'll freeze so exactly perhaps the
system actually is physically
transported away from the original
um and i think there's a a lot of value
in which to just say that
instead of distracting yourself with
this kind of combinatorial point of view
you can sort of embrace that there is
some element of this
unpredictability and this problem
statement and
this will be not just a defeatist
attitude but i think one that actually
leads to
a constructive method for kind of
thinking about this and just
some of the ways in which this tends to
happen in practice or for example
like i mentioned side reactions where
one reaction is simply much faster than
another you lead down a chain of them
you get to a pretty stable state
and just practically you never see the
rest come
and i think this is also an argument
that i'll make later but
these uh auto catalytic cycles of
kaufman where life kind of emerges via
this
scheme where things self-catalyze it's
very hard to tell exactly what size
that's going to happen at
and so where have we seen hints of this
in physics so it's always
very tempting in chemistry chemistry
feels very finite feels very discreet
uh rarely do we take these infinite
limits except for certain thermodynamic
problems
but in physics people love taking in to
infinity usually as a simplification
these kind of thermodynamic limits
and in analogy to that hcl problem we
had before
we already have some instances where you
take this limit and goes to infinity
and you have to do kind of a by-hand
correction so if you just take a 2d
ferromagnet icing model and you start
looking at you know it's symmetric it
could be all spin up all spin down
if i look at its thermodynamics without
doing anything i would conclude
basically that
uh the two lowest degenerate states
might have equal occupation and if you
just plow forward
you can end up with some some strange
results basically
but we fix this by saying oh no there's
spontaneous symmetry breaking
in fact there's not some exponential
probability that the infinite system
you know will flip or something like
this at zero temperature
we just exactly fraction it into one
part of space
and we give this a special term we call
it spontaneous symmetry breaking
but when this happens because not
because of symmetry because of something
else we have to invent a different term
for it
um so free energy landscapes of spin
glasses
we also take this n goes to infinity
limit and we start to see with these
strong potential landscapes but the real
physics of the system is described by
being locked into some glassy state
and as we take this n goes to infinity
limit we're not counting exponentially
small probabilities in some distant
basin we're in fact saying this new
gibbs measure not to be confused with
the gibbs state
exactly describes the system that i'm
i'm interested in
and so this game we've played before
where we use a little bit of
external data to kind of say that okay
this combinatorial view wasn't really
the one i wanted i'm going to use some
information
to help myself out a little bit
and just to make this uh talk a little
bit memorable
uh let's take one more even more extreme
example perhaps
of where kind of this undecidability can
come about
so it is of course a big open question
how uh
you know you take small reagent
molecules like ethanol methane etc
and these tend to combine and to make
things like
proteins uh which are then catalysts of
themselves
and in fact even the order of the arrows
that i'm showing now is highly
contentious
and this can lead to the emergence of
say dna which can act as both a
mechanist
and a information carrier and eventually
you get to something like an animal cell
and so each one of these feels like very
great qualitative changes
and even after i get to the point of
animal cell i can ask you a question
like
do you does human life ever emerge i try
to answer this question and then i see a
dinosaur come out and i say okay well
i'm tempted to say no
and then suddenly a meteor strikes and
we have reemergence
of human life and so certainly this is
not a proof
of despite connections of dna computing
to undecidability
but if you embrace this kind of
philosophical point of view that this
might be
useful which you'll hopefully be more
convinced of in a minute
these certainly feel like qualitative
changes that are very hard to predict
ahead of time
without actually just running it forward
and seeing what happens
so why am i spending all this time being
such a
uh downer why am i telling you that
there are these things which you can't
have algorithms to
compute and my argument is actually that
while this won't be a
perfect analogy there is this kind of
concept
uh at least in formal computer science
that i was taught about by some of my
collaborators
that undecidability can formally be
broken by advice
in some cases and something we showed
later
is that data is actually a restricted
form of advice and so this was kind of
this
conceptual epiphany that i had that in
fact data that came from our universe
um is a little bit more powerful than we
thought it was i won't claim that it
will solve undecidable problems that's
not
the point this is sort of just
inspiration but let me take you perhaps
on a small detour that will help you
convince you that this is
at least very relevant in all of our
considerations of the hardness
of quantum problems so let's take a very
brief
uh detour here so this will be the
section that
at least alludes to some result in
another paper which is new
rather than simply a conceptual overview
so i'm going to take a brief detour
to this hartree-fock experiment that we
did
i'm not going to go into too much detail
other than to say i want you to notice
the circuit on the top left
it is it works on these n qubits it's a
series of these rotations
and the most important thing to remember
from at least this point
is that this is a circuit which is easy
to evaluate classically
we know more or less everything about it
and it's a nice starting point for
adding more correlation and adding
more and more complexity to a quantum
circuit so that you can get better and
better descriptions of things
and it's been at least useful in some
cases to consider these circuits that
have
each of these angles in them we could
maybe train these angles
or parametrize them to fit some problem
that we're interested in
to kind of squint a little bit and
consider these like neural networks that
we can use to learn
and so there's in fact an enticing
connection with the classical community
so there were these problems with
vanishing gradients especially in very
long circuits
in say recurrent neural networks and
some
a group of compute machine learning
experts came up with these
potential solutions to it called
efficient unitary neural networks in
fact
the first iterations were these unitary
neural networks and the efficient ones
if you look at them
are actually exactly the implementations
you might be looking for
but i'll mention that in a second these
work by
feeding things into unitaries doing a
non-linearity so you don't just collapse
the whole thing
doing another unitary doing a
non-linearity and in fact the efficient
version is exactly the hartree thought
givens rotations that chemists have been
doing
for quite some time and so you look at
this and you're like okay
well this is a great opportunity if i'm
interested in the way that data
influences the hardness of problems to
come in and bring in
a quantum computer and just take an
existing working machine learning model
and just plug in a quantum device so i'd
like to to boost the power with quantum
since i already have this great
efficient reference point and i know i
can add quantum things to it to make it
more and more powerful
so the classical case has n inputs and n
outputs um
and a natural choice since we're talking
about chemistry
is to just use these fermionic
computation modes
and since especially these efficient
unitary neural networks are exactly
single particle uh fermionic rotations
and i'm going to beef up the power of
quantum with some new generators so
here's the circuit that i had
here's the effective dimension at the
bottom so right now it's just hard to
[ __ ]
everything's kind of rotating in just n
dimensions all the rest of my states
aren't that important
but now i'm going to add some particles
i'm going to interact them
i'm going to loop this construction many
many times i'm going to make this
a very hard circuit it can probably do
arbitrary computation
and then i'll destroy some particles or
just measure and renormalize
and i'll have n at the end so i've taken
n inputs
i've done blown things up into this
exponential space done arbitrary
computation
and then i've read out in outputs so
i've clearly
revolutionized machine learning and i'm
going to press forward and see how this
works so
we're doing a learning problem so let's
let our model have a little bit of data
as a tree
so i'm going to take in some data here
i'm just going to call it x
i and y i and these x i here will be
these pieces of data that come in as my
n
inputs which i've relabeled p to keep
you on your toes
uh and now i have this long quantum
neural network u
which i allow to be of totally arbitrary
length and i have this hermitian
operator o in the middle
that's going to correspond to my outputs
as long as i give myself ancilla
this is in fact i can make an arbitrary
computation in here
and so direct simulation must be at
least as hard as vqp
and because it's infinite length it's
probably harder
and i want to look at what my outputs
actually look like so i take my n inputs
i take this operator o
and i simply expand it out i do a little
math and i have this
matrix b k l which i've told you is
basically
as hard to compute as doing anything in
quantum computation
but this is at most a quadratic function
of x i with p squared coefficients and
basically what's happened here
is that with no data this is a hard
quantum circuit
and with a quadratic amount of data this
is almost a trivial learning task
and so this is kind of the start of a
realization because this was
kind of the trivial case of what happens
if you're just kind of input and output
dimensions
are constrained in the wrong way and
you're like wait a minute there seems to
be
an issue here where having a little bit
of data has fundamentally
changed the complexity of this task and
this was kind of the quest
uh the problem that set us off on a
quest um
and i mentioned that my collaborator
robert fong did almost do the hard
computer science work here
where in fact he was able to show that
there is a different complexity class
where you were
endowed with the power of data that
comes from a quantum computer
and this allows a classical learning
algorithm with a little bit of data
to solve problems that previously only a
quantum computer could
solve and so for me this was like a big
conceptual uh
revelation even if one that's like a
little bit against
uh you know this idea that quantum is
strictly more powerful
and so i won't talk about the proof here
but just to say that this was an
inspiring
uh point for me and one that i had hoped
to share both with the chemical
community
and otherwise and so in fact
if you look towards a problem like
chemical synthesis you can't help but
start to notice
hints of where we've made choices based
on say input and data
so i mentioned this very hard problem of
synthesizability
there is this whole field called natural
product synthesis where
you take a a very hard you take some
molecule from nature
often which has some nice property i
think the one that i depicted here
has some anti-cancer properties and then
you ask
how do you best make this from simple
reagents that i can order off the shelf
and one of the big questions that it
actually answers is was this molecule
synthesizable
at all so if you talk to people that are
in
for example screening projects where you
try to design new molecules and test
properties and do many many different
iterations of say
new photovoltaics or new drugs or things
like that
you'll find that a nearly universal
problem that they have is they reach the
final list of candidates the properties
all check
out they go deliver these candidates to
a
chemist the chemist looks at them and
says
i don't think you can make any of these
no one knows how to synthesize them
then a phd student goes off spend five
years trying
never succeeds and sort of we don't
really have a single property that we
know how to compute on a molecule that
tells us if it's synthesizable
but what we do have is data from the
natural world that suggests certain
pieces are more synthesizable than
others by virtue of common side
reactions kinetics thermodynamics and
things like that
and often chemists are very good sources
of just glancing at a molecule
and knowing if you can make it or not
and to me this idea that you could
take instead of this combinatorial
perspective of say i took this molecule
at the left
blew it up into its atoms rearranged
them aggressively
and tried to do calculations to say if
any of these things were potential uh
synthesis routes or i can take the point
of view on the right this undecidable
point of view which is to say i'm going
to take a
a data-driven uh solution to my problem
and i can look in chemical catalogs and
tell you have these
large fragments ever been produced and
how um and this might be a more
viable route to this problem and then
as if one blow wasn't enough and the
same author and collaborators uh
went on to show a different result which
he talked about at this conference
which was that in fact for certain
systems
in condensed matter physics with a
little bit of data you can now sort of
provably solve nearby problems and they
go on to do numerics and show that in
fact
you can do often even better than this
in several phases at the same time
and so this inspires a question of well
chemistry is a little more discreet than
some condensed matter systems adding one
or two molecules
to the system or one or two atoms can
cause dramatic property changes like it
might
not be soluble in water anymore or
things like this this isn't really a
phase change in the traditional
definition in physics
but it's a very discreet and very
dramatic uh change to a system
and if all of these results turn out to
be true while it will be very useful to
use a quantum computer to build
learning models uh that can very
accurately predict chemistry
if the fate of quantum computers and
chemistry is to provide training data
for classical models
i think we'd all be a little bit
disappointed for one of the most
exciting
and fundamental technologies that
humanity's ever tried to work on
um but luckily the same author in a
different one at
the same time dropped another result
which is still along the lines of what
you can do with data on a quantum
computer
um and so i believe that uh at least one
of these was talked about at this
conference
but basically this result said that if
you had
a quantum computer and you could bring
in quantum states
instead of just measurements about them
there was in fact some things a quantum
computer could allow you to learn about
the universe
which would require exponentially more
samples than that classical
case and so if i'm following this theme
that data from the natural
world is in fact not only powerful like
a quantum computer but one that's run
for a very long time
uh and that this is a very powerful
concept i should take forward
what i've now learned is that quantum
computers can help me learn about that
those results much much faster in some
cases
and so this kind of brings back your
your optimism and you start to feel like
okay
maybe this is where i should be looking
for the new frontiers and so what does
that
kind of look like i should say that in
this perspective we have a transition
point where we start to
speculate about the future and that's
kind of where we're at now
um and so hopefully you'll enjoy some of
these musings but they're they're not so
concrete
and so you have to imagine a future with
multi-cubic quantum data to really see
these these advantages and so chemical
systems should interact with some
quantum sensor
you can either do direct measurements
which is what we do today like
destructive measurements and process
but what we've learned from these recent
papers and in some cases as few as two
copies or a few copies
that transduction and this quantum
computer lets us make predictions or
store records of these systems with
exponentially fewer copies
and so it's kind of interesting because
in my mind it flips a bit the narrative
of quantum sensing
traditionally when you talk about
quantum sensing you talk about learning
perhaps a single phase with one qubit
or many qubits that form an effective
like large ghc state to increase
sensitivity
but that's usually like a kind of
quadratic-ish speed up and turning up
the brightness of your light can
kind of overcome this sometimes but what
these results are saying is that
transduction of multi-cubit states are
exponentially more powerful
and i think we need to think more about
what that might mean for the future of
sensors
for example chemists are some of the
first to embrace you know
these original quantum sensors of nmr
but these are usually kind of effective
single qubit dqc1 like sensors
and there might be some hope and say
spatially resolved diamond sensors or
perhaps zero fuel this is again wild
speculation
and i think it's always fruitful to look
at some untapped technology and quantum
computing within chemistry
so for example the technology and error
correction in clifford states can
express some
almost very powerful entanglement
structures but the ones that are
efficient
to simulate and easy to combine with
these kind of archery fock rotations
after the fact so you can do at least as
well as archery [ __ ]
and there is some at least tantalizing
connection for something that can be
expressed as grass states
and molecules which have this very
natural graph expression to them
and as an untapped additional question
does this
part which makes transition metal
catalysts hard to simulate which is just
quasi-degeneracy oscillator determinants
relate in any way to the ways in which
error correcting codes
uh protect information through
degeneracy
i'm not sure but certainly that's a fun
uh part to probe
and kind of last uh but not least
of these kind of additional things one
might use is that we have this
large history of quantum control in
chemistry and
i think that you know what we do now is
we do these measurements and we do these
feedback loops
sort of analog control and what we
learned from say a bit of quantumeric
correction
is that in fact some of these
measurements don't need to be
destructive if you have some quantum
probe in the system
you can start to do measurements that
not only create preserve entanglement
but actually create it
and allow you to say start stabilizing
exotic quantum states
in your chemical system perhaps it
helped catalyze different
pieces of it and finally if we could
really loop in this digital connection
where we now can get to these kind of
provable error correction regimes
what does that mean for the
stabilization of exotic chemistry states
like exatons or
polariton couplings maybe strong cavity
chemistry
and again this is just some things that
i feel chemists might have overlooked in
the development of say
quantum error correction that i feel
like could make an interesting
back port and so taking back another
look at computational chemistry that's
kind of a brief summary of what we've
talked about
i've argued in a very hand-wavy way that
many problems in design
synthesis and biology feel like
undecidable problems this is not a proof
what can we say about the way that data
from nature
helps us and whether this perspective is
not perhaps correct but is a useful
perspective
um data from quantum computers can lift
classical machine learning above its
direct simulation competition
what can quantum simulation data
actually do for chemistry how can we
we start to use this uh knowledge to
better plan for the future
is the fate of quantum computers largely
to provide data
uh i certainly hope not um but how do we
start to look
towards sensors in the future where this
can be true and are there any
untapped tools from quantum computing
that can help chemistry before a full
quantum computer
and so maybe you'd like at least one
tagline before we end which is to say
that
we had this bold question what the
foundations of quantum computer science
teach us about chemistry
and i was referring largely to these
recent results that say that
data is more powerful than we think it
is and i think what we can learn
uh from quantum computers is hopefully
uh
how to access the natural world in an
even more
uh important and aggressive way i'll say
with that i'd just like to thank all of
the collaborators who were involved in
this work
those were brave enough that to be on
this paper where we did some wild
speculation
and i hope that you at least found the
discussion a bit fun and engaging
even if you disagree with some of the
points that i've made and
i'd like to thank you all for listening
thanks
fix up your questions
and there's a question so uh is there
uh anything you can say about how that
uh complexity class
i forget what it was called um
which one so you're referring to say
like the bpp
samp class yeah yeah so bpp sam so can
you say anything about how that compares
to having like
just like an oracle to a quantum
algorithm
ah so i suppose
i'm probably the wrong person to answer
this question
but the setting it might be similar for
example to having access
no actually that's not true uh so one of
the problems we examine
in the appendix of the the paper is one
in which
uh say in this setting you can imagine
problems in which you get get
some training data and now the classical
machine learning algorithm only needs to
embed your data
using a classical computer so it can
still it doesn't have access to a
quantum oracle but it's still now as
powerful as some quantum tasks
but there are other tasks where the
embedding actually needs to be a quantum
embedding
and this is kind of these factoring like
problems so in that case that would
probably be more close to the setting
you're thinking of where
i have access to a quantum oracle while
i'm in the prediction phase so i think
they're maybe distinct in that sense
there's a question in the q a do you
have any findings about the digital
analog
interfaces techniques such as dqc1
complexity and sensors
so i don't have any results myself i can
point
interested people to problems where
people have studied
nmr uh sort of the this
measurement of nmr signals in the
context of dqc1 i think maybe
i'm forgetting that there was two or
three papers but if people remind me or
i have time after i can paste them into
the the chat
basically the the feeling is that you're
getting an essentially classical signal
out from coupling to this quantum one
um and the quantum when you're doing nmr
because spin spacings are so close
are so close together um you can
essentially view it as an infinite
temperature thermal state and yet you
still extract
information from time time correlations
on that thermal state
but i can point people to the papers but
i don't personally have any new results
on that
um that was a really nice talk to it uh
so i have a quick question
uh um you know you spoke about
collecting this quantum data or through
transducing so is that something i
should think of as being
easy to do or is that in principle
something to do so
once you create am i am i thinking
correctly that you you
once you once you create this chemical
molecule you want to actually
do measurements on it and these are now
general quantum measurements or
something or you want to take that as an
input to
a quantum computer so is that is that
something that's
how should i think of the complex you
know
yeah so in terms of practical complexity
i think um this kind of depends on the
problem the
setup and what you want to learn a
little bit maybe i'll give a few
examples so uh really to see these huge
advantages
in learning um as was done in some of
these follow-up papers
you want it to be multi-cubit quantum
information and you'd like it to be
about the molecule in a
in a perfect world you could say
transduce the state of the molecule into
the quantum computer but that's
obviously
um not really feasible probably even
from a physical perspective
um and so you would imagine attaching uh
say nitrogen vacancies a diamond like an
array of them so that you can get
correlated spatial uh
information as well as the quantum
information
but in this setup you then need to get
it into a computational medium where you
can at least do
do clifford gates on it and so i would
say at the moment the state of
multi-qubit quantum sensors that can do
this
is somewhat limited for chemistry but
i do feel that um some systems are a bit
better adapted to this point of view
than say
the superconducting qubits we use so
it's not uncommon right now to build
quantum sensors out of say very
elaborate setups with
atom interferometry so those atoms are
already single atoms are already very
good sensors of something like
gravitational fields or other signals
and if you can advance at the same time
your ability to compute in atoms then
you no longer have this transduction
problem
so you go out and you use your atom
fountain to do
some type of measurement you store that
quantum state in the atoms
and now it's also your computational
medium so you don't have to do
any kind of transduction to accomplish
this i should say that
if you need to do substantial
computation you also need to do an
encoding step into an error correcting
code
but this is kind of counted as the
fidelity of transduction and i don't
think you need to have
perfect fidelity to do that but once
you've done it you can go on so if
you're in a system like atoms or ions i
think
you might already be not that far from a
multi-qubit quantum system
that can both be a sensor and a computer
if you're in a system like super
conducting qubits
and your target is an atom or molecule
then you kind of need to go through a
chain of steps and i believe that's
quite far from realization
but what these most recent results tell
me is that
you know these strong query complexity
results don't permit as much classical
competition as all the problems we're
having with
making ground states and so i think this
helps motivate the development of that
kind of sensor because
um maybe i'm rambling too much but i
used to be
very much closer to chemistry labs
themselves and people
in these labs looked at quantum sensing
for a little while and they concluded
that
because of the brightness of sources and
the quadratic at most speed up it wasn't
a great use of
their time but if there was an
exponential speed up i feel like that
attitude might change and so yeah
all right a couple more questions in the
um q a
would you see an application of quantum
computers in the digital plus analog
to quantum chemistry go beyond data from
qc let's see would you see an
application number
it's analog data from quantum computers
so maybe that's asking um if you do some
kind of digital analog
simulation does this have a
value beyond producing data or maybe the
question is
can this do things you can't do with
just collected data
and i maybe answering the second
supposition of that question first
is that the provable results sort of
pertain to
at least so far data often within a same
phase which is where
properties tend to change somewhat
slowly so prediction
via extrapolation is somewhat reliable
once you cross phase boundaries or do
strange things with chemicals sometimes
properties change almost discontinuously
and so i'd say in that case having
access to the quantum computer so long
as you can then
prepare new things in a different phase
that had no data still has
value of course but once you have a lot
of data in each of those phases
i think what these results suggest is
that with
not that much data um that might be good
for those systems the
most value in the system is in bringing
you data from new ones
and i think that's kind of a challenge
for analog simulators since they're
built for
one particular type of system
last question of was it stated that
reading or writing
information influenced chemistry
you see that question there was it
stated that reading or writing
information
influenced chemistry i'm not sure
exactly
what that question means but i do think
information theory has
positively influenced chemistry it's
used in a number of
number of areas um but i'm not exactly
sure what that means
all right well let's thank jared again
great thank you